renoncer à ce fulco d'hiver durera c'est
un appartient à la noblesse
l'aristocratie sicilienne il né en 1899
une famille d'aristocrates sicilien de
très très vieille souche de souche
espagnole sous ce qu'on peut imaginer de
plus noble pour la sicile et avec cette
particularité qui a été peut-être la
raison pour laquelle je suis intéressé à
ce livre c'est que ce sont les
principaux personnages du livre c'est à
dire sa grand mère et son grand-père qui
ont été utilisés par le prince de l'amp
et du son cousin pour devenir angélique
et cora d'or du guépard
alors je pense que là il ya toute une
série ce bon ce sont ses souvenirs entre
l'âge de 5 ans ou etihad et qui généré 5
ans peut être on peut dire que ça à
mémoire d'un enfant là il faudrait en
discuter je crois qu'elle est en réalité
plus ancienne que ça qu on vraiment
qu'un petit garçon une petite fille
quatre ans commence à avoir vraiment à
12 ans ils se souviennent de ce qu'ils
ont été à quatre ans comme ça commence à
4 ans ça doit finir autour des années 14
15 ans l'âge de la mort de sa grand mère
puisqu'il n'ya pas de celui que c'était
à la recherche du temps perdu mais
plutôt à la recherche des lieux perdus
oui à une fascination extradition pour
tous les lieux sur le décor il est
inquiet je pense que ça s'explique aussi
par le fait qu'il a écrit le livre très
très vieux deux ans avant sa mort il
avait 78 ans dans une sorte de panique
de retrouver son enfance et de se dire
qu'il a été le dernier témoin d'une
façon de vivre sur la disparue et qui
s'ils ne la raconte pas super oui sept
non moi je trouve ça formidable adore ça
alors ces lieux bon il ya une villa ça
s'appelle la ville à aniche ennemis
j'aime et oui chez me suis une ville
absolument superbe
oui c'est là c'est en fait ce que je dis
dans la postface cette espèce le folie
de villégiature que gaulle dounia a
tellement bien compris lui dans le nord
de l'italie c'est l'italie saisi par le
démon de la villégiature plus personne
ne pouvait rester chez soi même quand ce
chez soi était un palais dont on ne
pouvait pas compter le nombre des pièces
il fallait aller s'installer à la
campagne
même quand on était menacée par la ruine
c'est la folie de la villégiature alors
il s'installe en dehors de palerme
ils ne vont naturellement plus du tout
sur leurs terres comme de toute manière
il ne savait pas combien d'hectares ô
combien de ces terres il ne connaissait
pas il ne gérait pas bon ils sont
menacés par la ruine mais ils ont le
cette fameuse maison il faut qu'ils
aient et qui fascine le petit garçon
foule coop c'est le paradis terrestre